[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
one oh seven three seven four one eight
two four
one eight two four
don't be scared that tree's got your
hair
as a father we let go
as a father we let go time is Limitless
[Music]
below
one oh seven three seven four one eight
two four
[Music]
to four
one oh seven three seven
don't be scared
[Music]
let go
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right what's up guys I'll just give
you a quick little update
um as to what's going on so we're just
like preparing basically
we're just like uh getting like the
whiteboard in the background set up and
this the theme is going to be released
about 10 minutes the countdown is like
here
3D space is hard ah there it is
and the possible themes are these
because that's the last running round so
it's gonna be one of those basically
basically guaranteed to be one of
those themes
um
all right
any questions no great I'll see you soon
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right stream can you guys hear me
well I got this little mic just for you
right here next to the Whiteboard so you
can hopefully hear well so let me know
might be a bit quiet maybe I'll tell
is this better testing one two three
stream
well that like what
one minute 15 seconds left
yeah if you can hear me all right good
uh
24 seconds
six seconds five four three two one
what's the theme
delivery the worst theme the first one
that I hated that I voted down it's
delivery that's so predictable I hate
that
ah
all right
now
I didn't really want it to be delivery
to be completely honest
supervr thank you for the Super Chat
appreciate the support uh any the
question was is there anything else
other than SML that I would recommend to
make games
um in simple Sports
that's a hard question to answer like
sfml is pretty good as far as like just
Staples Frameworks go you could always
try using something like Walnut and
doing everything yourself which is
something I made if you followed the
Genesis series remaking my first game
like in from Java disables Plus on my
channel that has a little bit more of
kind of like doing things Yourself by
like managing a pixel right that could
be fun for retro games
all right
so let's give
computer a call
stream let me know how the uh volume
ends up being like for because I just
called Peter
what's up
all right what's up Peter
what's the delivery
yeah can you believe it that was like
the the theme that I voted down that
theme to be honest I also voted down it
we all voted down that Fame and yet it's
delivery the hair of course
oh I don't know I just didn't like
delivery because I feel like it's so
pretty like it's just like it's too
simple you know you want something with
a bit more spice
yeah I mean I guess I obviously it's as
simple as you make it but still like I
wanted something oh my what was that one
that I wanted the uh your health bar is
not just a health bar I wanted that
thing
I just didn't want to admit it uh
uh anyways um I set up the GitHub repo
yep okay do you want to quickly listen
to My Stream and Save
you sound good
uh yeah
[Music]
they'll probably be quite a bit of delay
though because I didn't play with the
latent sandal
uh I mean I'm very echoey
yeah it's probably because it's both
through the speakers so we can hear and
also through the mic
yeah that Mark's December yeah
I don't really know what we could do
apart from where headphones which we're
not going to do so
yeah I mean no well the other obviously
the other thing we could do
is just not like
it's just not like you know if we stop
desktop audio and then you're fully
through the mic through the mic then
people will hear you as if you're in the
room so try try speaking now
all right I'm gonna try speaking
hopefully it sounds better that's a
little quiet
there's quite a delay on your stream
did you manage to turn it off on yours
uh yeah I set the latency to low
it's not the lowest setting but
I don't really care about stream delay
it's fine it's like 30 seconds it's fine
all right
um all right anyway five minutes in
we've done nothing so delivery
stream chat suggest us stuff either that
or I'm taking this to chat jbt you'll
you'll move
good idea I had a bad idea like a
throwaway idea yesterday because
somebody's gonna do it so it might as
well be us it's a game about like pizza
delivering so if you're not delivering
pizzas but you're like on ubereats or
whatever you're delivering babies that
way
um and so it's delivery on both damn
that's so you think we should go with
the idea you said someone was definitely
going to go with yeah that's why I said
it might as well be us right
I I mean kind of like like the idea of
pizza delivery like I feel like
I'm picturing something like dichotomy
but you're in those like you're on those
tiles basically jumping around and you
have to deliver a pizza
so dichotomy too right it's the same
thing it's just instead of getting to
the flag you're holding a pizza and you
just need to get to the person who wants
it which is the flag
so that's great and I think we might
actually be able to do that in an hour
if we yeah if we use existing libraries
aka the full game we'll just have to opt
out of every single category now but
pizza delivery I like that idea I don't
know I feel like Tim Tim could do some
pretty good pizza art I feel like okay
as well
yeah so like I I'm just imagining like
this sort of pizza delivery guy just
going through absolute hell like a
Warsaw right yeah that's a cool setting
absolutely failed with bullets or
something yeah in an apocalypse so
there's zombies to fight yes yeah not
bad I I would say war zone pizza
delivery there's like artillery raining
down and so that's cool because there's
lots of particles lots of explosions
going on which is which will be cool
lots of physics objects yes
um and you just have to yeah but but
that's the setting right so you're a
character you have to deliver a pizza
isn't this kind of boring though like if
you think of the theme delivery is pizza
not like the most obvious thing like is
this what if you have this is
oh
what if what if what if there's a twist
what if you think you're developing
you're delivering Health packs but
actually you're delivering the nuclear
launch codes or something I don't know
in the health in on or in the pizza they
open the pizza and on the inside is like
the nuclear launch code
but that's pizza again I think we should
probably get pizza for dinner yeah
I mean I like the idea of this stream is
saying a lot completely I'm not actually
listening to it let me okay so let's see
what stream's saying thanks um someone
for the super via Arts the two super VR
again with the Super Chat also I was
recently trying to learn about July suck
LOL any course or guide I have a series
of videos on open jail on my channel you
can check that out otherwise like
learningpicturel.com's pretty decent
they have some good guest articles as
well not by me but they're good anyway
um all right so base delivery all the
way death stranding anatomically correct
of the baby delivery maybe a stalk
delivery is like so meh yeah I agree I
don't like delivery no one's going with
that idea whatever why not top down GTA
one slash two style pizza delivery well
we want to do kind of like a we want to
do a game that almost looks like
dichotomy a bit like isn't it's going to
be that kind of maybe top down isometric
e perspective
ninja pizza delivery
Domino's free 30 minutes to Mars that's
funny piece of planets maybe no I don't
think I want to do anything with planets
but I already made a game with planets
the I think evacuate game that won the
audio category
not today
I'm just replying to chat
yeah playing delivering packages that
just reminds me of Sebastian's like yeah
this is like little game oh zero x what
about a game about joke delivery that's
funny you're you're being delivered and
you have to avoid it
you're being delivered oh you've been
like kidnapped by a Mexican that player
is being delivered somewhere
yeah
I really like the war zone setting
though with the stuff like raining down
because I feel like that's kind of cool
that was kind of project Orange right
part of it yeah yeah in a way I guess so
yeah yeah
to you
just deliver houses to Paces that's
funny
yeah what if it's an inverse world where
pizzas are living and they're delivering
houses or whatever well they're
delivering people
Mark in my chat is what does chat apt
think I don't really want to find out
what'd you say put on
uh Marco in my chat is nabbing ideas
from us
yeah that that sounds like him
um well yeah I really like Warsaw
um and that has a lot of physics right
well yeah I mean anything can happen
what if it's PESA but like every every
piece of every every topping is like a
physics object
oh you have to catch a little bit okay
check this out yeah the whole game is
about assembling a pizza yeah but it's
like hard to do because everything is a
physics subject and it's like falling
off but you have to keep it together and
put in the oven and then it melts and we
use some of that fluid Dynamic stuff
that you added right Peter and uh
don't we have buoyancy in Hazel yeah
well that's not too late
um
that's kind of fun or or the war zone
thing is ingredients flying down and you
have to run around with a pizza and put
them on the pizza like you have to get
there in time you know so you have like
timers hey yeah pepperoni falling down
here yeah
yeah you like you think it's like
artillery fire and then you slowly
discover that it's actually your like
Allied kind of Truth sending support
care packages but they're actually
individual Pizza ingredients um
and then you can fry up the pizza on the
uh nuclear fallout
make it crispy
yeah yeah you're like a mad scientist
cooking himself
in between of work and look on a nuke
yeah
um yeah I don't know I so okay so so far
what do we like let's maybe put this on
the Whiteboard and stream let me know if
you can see the Whiteboard I know it's a
bit white and hard to see but you know
we should get a Blackboard
um all right so
yeah so I think we're pretty sad on war
zone and pizza right
yeah I think that that's gonna be very
interesting I guess there's no reason
now that we're not doing the doubling up
thing there's no reason not to move this
whiteboard closer
foreign
okay so we're
delivering pizza in a war zone
delivering or assembling Pizza
oh
assembling Pizza no um
well we have to do something like the
theme's delivery right so it has to have
something to do with delivery yeah
um
I don't know like I'm just more thinking
like I don't know if
so at the moment what we're actually
thinking that like we're in like a war
zone it's kind of isometric here right
you're a guy you're not a we wanted to
avoid cubes so you're a sphere oh I mean
what if you have to what if you remember
how I was talking about the physics
rolling around thing
no that's I don't know how it's gonna
fit here uh we wouldn't make it like a
sphere why not make a playable character
yeah yeah no I don't know
that would be good
um animations
we're gonna have actual proper
animations more than one yeah
so running around
so this is my idea maybe I'll give you
guys this is too bland this is too bland
this is what I think I think instead of
like the war zone like rockets flying
down it's ingredients and so you're
running around in the Square you have to
collect all the ingredients right you
know this pizza has to have three
pepperonis on it I don't know one
mushroom
um two cheese or whatever right so you
can't have more you have more like
um I don't know what happens something
has to bad happen but basically you
can't no one ever refused a pizza
because it had too many toppings
said
[Music]
um get some food for thought the Berlin
blockade basically food and resources he
would say that he's from Germany
yeah it's so yeah after you've assembled
this piece
you have to like deliver it through a
war zone where like you're getting
attacked
but it's kind of like Warzone is first
good it's wearing the ingredients and
then bad it's I don't know I don't know
like I'm almost thinking it might be
better for us to steer clear from Pizza
yeah I just feel like delivery and pizza
go hand in hand and also deliver
packages
yeah Pizza package they're not unique
enough yeah yeah which is why again
nuclear bomb yeah like something yeah
some war zone something like that yeah
because like you don't you don't
typically have a guy just running around
with a nuclear bomb for delivery
purposes well I mean this is a video
game so it could be anything
I mean I guess it depends on like do we
want the delivery thing to be like part
of the war theme so like you're
delivering something that you would
typically have in like a war zone or do
we want to make it like you're
delivering something comical
well someone said delivering deliver a
message in a war zone would be really
cool
yeah I don't know I feel like yeah like
delivering a message might actually be
cool
yeah
yeah oh you've seen 1917 right yeah yeah
like that kind of thing you know like he
just has to go till the commander not to
attack basically you know
um that's actually based on a
programming problem the two generals uh
problem oh really oh really I didn't
know that's cool well well the two
generals problem is like a real war
problem but it applies to um programming
online transactions okay
who's the authority basically
well more like you can't accidentally
send the same message twice and then you
actually I don't remember the exact on
all the exact application for it but I
know it is wait so the way it is is like
two generals problem is a real problem
in real life right then a code problem
derived that but then a war movie is
based on the code problem not the
original I imagine the warp war movie is
based on the actual concept of the two
general problems in war
it's just uh with uh
TCP networking you also that also can
apply
when you where you feed cannibals
different animals and they mutate
how's the stream you guys have some
messed up ideas
deliver a suitcase for a hitman
hmm
I mean it would be interesting like if
it is sort of a play of the two generals
struggle which
is like you know you have
um and it's programming problem
[Music]
Ah that's too Natty
not enough also No One's Gonna Get that
it's like outside
participating in the game jams yeah
I'll be a fair enough I'm just the ideas
man I'm not gonna write any code
out of here I'm gonna see that guitar
over there I'm gonna be playing I'm
gonna be making the music for this game
the whole time
maybe maybe we'll win the audio category
again
yeah
um all right
I I kind of also like like the idea of
something to do with coffee
like what if coffee run what if like
yeah what if coffee is like running out
or something and like you really like
it's like we make a comical to the
severity of which like it's like
basically what if you are in fact
delivering a certain package in a war
zone but you don't know what's inside
and along the way you get hints and
hints and hints and then it turns out
it's just like coffee beans because that
was like the most important thing
like the general needs his coffee and
it's it's running out yeah spin on the
idea you're surrounded in a war zone
right there's five fronts or whatever
yeah and there's a coffee station in the
middle and what you're doing is you run
into the coffee station and delivering
it to like the five generals or whatever
like you know like the one that gets
tired like they're from like Advantage
like they'll lose ground overcooked
that's what I was thinking of yeah I
think that's the thing I don't know well
that's like a little it's like a you're
working in a kitchen you have to like
slice some stuff up and bring it there
in his Co-op and so ah no that one I
have yeah
but here someone said you play as a
YouTuber and you deliver content to your
fan base that's too real guys come on
yeah
yeah too close to home
that's too much
Yeah
the code to a company you work for
that's in a different country
yeah
no that's also hitting too close to home
for you Peter
so coffee Warzone Pizza is dropping off
I think
yeah no pizza okay no pizza pizza is
officially gone
so Warzone coffee
I am actually like I kind of want to
plug this into chat gbt being like write
me a game about what a war zone and
coffee
but like that's just me being lazy and
not wanting to think
but I'm just curious but maybe I'll do
that later I don't want to do it yet no
AI for now
so now on the overcooked gameplay
and if you're too rough maybe like nah
yeah I don't think so I don't want it to
be too like
you know running around kind of
delivering stuff within set time frames
I I that's the other thing I don't wanna
I don't want this to be time based I
don't think yeah I think let's just make
it like a little fun game that
let's make a fun game going to become
annoying yeah well exactly I don't want
this to be like stressful even though
it's in a war zone which is funny like
that's good that's a juxtaposition
um I think also that like but what could
be stressful is not time wise but like
quality right so maybe you've got like
this nice latte or something that's been
created and you have to deliver it to
the general but if you're a little bit
if like if you get into too many
conflicts with enemies along the way
then like the latte art is ruined and
the general is gonna like hit you
yeah that's what I would do
so I think um
that'd be kind of fun yeah I feel like
yeah I feel like that's cool because
it's kind of like you have a product to
deliver and it's almost like I want to
fight enemies and I'm good at fighting
enemies like as in the enemies are
usually beatable like they're not
challenging but if you engage in too
many conflicts that degrades the product
so maybe that forces you to be a little
bit stealthy sometimes because you just
can't afford to get into another fight
that might ruin the product
yeah
hi
I'm liking it
you guys have so many ideas not writing
all of them
yeah some Physics game not trying to
Spill the coffee oh man if we had fluid
like proper fluid simulation
we might have together no but like it
could be abstract like what if we put a
thousand cubes into a container and if
any of them fall out
or if like the more Fallout you have a
certain percentage of them fall out you
know we can do that the only thing is
we'd have to limit the number of cubes
in that kind of closed confinement just
because with the version of Hazel we're
using
together it's not going to run too well
so
well it doesn't exist
yeah oh yeah by the way stream we want
to ship this game on Linux for all of
you nerds out there
let's not get that seems to be a
recurring theme today no it's yeah
um um but we're definitely I imagine we
could at least do a hundred we might
even be able to do a thousand
yeah so I think it could be kind of cool
yeah like that would be cool I guess
just because it'd be really easy like if
any of those cubes like for example fall
on the ground and the ground like a
trigger then it could detect how many
times it gets triggered or whatever and
that's like
that would just be like yeah you've lost
too much coffee
yeah
um
but that could be annoying I don't know
so not first person definitely fixed
camera yeah I think so I think I still
think this would be nice isometrically
or like kind of like the economy well no
it doesn't have to be asymmetric like we
could make the camera orbit around
because the economy is like really fixed
but this could be like orbit but that
same kind of level of
so like it would really just rotate
basically around the y axis you know
yeah
you could do something really
interesting with that where you
I mean you would probably want the
camera like a at a bit of an angle uh
like
a 45 degree angle looking kind of down a
bit and then just orbit around the
player
Yeah Yeah well yeah no I mean I kind of
I kind of like that idea if the mouse
yeah just controls the rotation but it's
on one it's one one axis it's just on
white and then you can um
like wasd or whatever can move so it's
kind of real time in that sense
but we don't unfortunately the one
problem with uh making it a real
character animation is I don't think we
have
I don't know zero X if you're watching
what's our deal with blending with blend
States and animations doesn't exist
right
yeah but I'm just curious if he just
said he goes yeah now but from uh from
What's called the partner he said yeah
blending is like coming but non-existent
young I know he's been working on it I'm
just curious what state it's in right
pun intended States I mean it wouldn't
be like a studio Channel while I'm there
if we're not using like top of this if
we didn't experimental if we didn't add
a major feature during yeah basically
yeah or requests and the thing is I have
as we discussed like I have no major
features to add at the moment because I
actually finished my work on time for
once what that sounds is like yarn is
doing blending this [__] this
foreign
what if you're a coffee mug why in a war
zone yeah why have a player what if
you're a mug
what if you're a coffee man
and you shoot out coffee at enemies and
that could be a joke about how coffee is
being fought over like oil
but then what's the delivery now
yeah I don't know the delivery of the
joke and if you shoot too many enemies
then you don't have any more coffee
so the general can't drink you
all right now I don't know I don't know
yeah
no but I do like the idea of like
coffee delivery
because like I don't know yeah animals
it sounds like a comical element to the
whole war zone thing
yeah especially if we're dramatize the
war zone well yeah it's like the most
important thing is the coffee
yeah
yeah which stands true in real life as
well so something with delivery drawings
someone said live a livery delivery
library delivery
this is this is the potential as well so
it's like 1917 so you're running across
like a front right
delivering a coffee and the reason why
the war was started is because the
coffee is late so the moment you deliver
the coffee the war ends happy end
yeah but but you have to go through
maybe there's two countries that are
like bordering like the first thing that
came to mind was like um Germany and
France because where I kind of grew up a
little bit in Germany it was like
literally on the border of France yeah
and so I could imagine someone ordering
a coffee from France
but who's you know in Germany so like
uber eatsing basically like a coffee and
like never arrives and that person
happens to be like a general or some the
president the president whatever and
like they're like yeah and they're like
um
yes yeah just death to the French
basically yeah it should be a coffee and
croissant then right if it's from France
yeah yeah exactly coffee and a croissant
nah but that's like difficult to set up
I think
yeah it would be
you mean like the actual gameplay of it
well just the hot like the setup it's
too complicated
like some one ordered I mean of course
you could be vague and reveal more of
the story as the time goes on but still
no I I think like again Simplicity and
what I would really like us to do
honestly is just develop some good
gameplay yeah you know I'd rather spend
our time developing gameplay rather than
trying to like write an a narrative just
because I feel like like narrative based
games are probably not the best to do in
a game Jam because you clearly don't
have much time and then you'll just end
up providing a linear story
that again obviously would have no
replayability
um and so I think if it's just like if
the concept if it's just a loose concept
that's quite vague
but then you
like the gameplay itself is obviously
fun
I think that would be better
yeah for us to do
yeah
I agree with that like if we want some
story elements we can do what we did
with forest and if we have some time
over at the end we can just slap
something in real quick someone said
deliver coffee to soldiers while being
bombarded if you spill too much your
soldiers will fall asleep and die hmm
if there's not enough coffee for the
whole team
oh yeah that's kind of like the idea of
um overcooked right like gameplay
I've seen yeah I guess so some people
have so many people have mentioned like
online multiplayer
in haze
definition yeah
just go and go ahead and
add real quick
so I can't believe the theme is delivery
that's possibly like the worst boring do
you want to be what was what were the
offer oh we can see the the accounts
like it's in the um probably the how
many votes what the score what the score
was for each team I don't know if that's
released already eventually yes I don't
know if that's already a thing I don't
think even the like countdown like from
the jam is up here
uh no the countdown hasn't started for
the end
which is strange because that usually
comes up quickly
so do we want to go with we're
delivering coffee to a general or are we
going to go with delivering coffee to
the soldiers and they dive you're too
slow or if there's not enough
no I think I I like the general idea
more just because I think it's funny
that like um
that's what he requires you know but but
also he could be the one Distributing it
to the soldiers anyway
uh so
thought would require us to have so are
we doing like we have a bunch of cubes
in in like a coffee mug and you can
spill the cubes
I don't know because how would that work
like we'd have I just mean like
Tim like is gonna make a character and
then the character is going to be
carrying a coffee mug and then the
coffee mug is going to have cute like
but this is usually
I don't even know like sounds like it
might actually be a bit too complicated
yeah this is too complicated it needs to
be really simple about that economy it
was like a positive game it was very
simple like game mechanics like
complicated but simple too like it's not
you don't need like a whole team of
developers working for like a month to
make a decent product out of it yeah it
was double in three days this way I
don't know all of this stuff is kind of
too much maybe
you can deliver a game for letting that
um
yeah well okay so let's flash let's
flash I guess we'll flesh out that idea
then so we're in a war zone we're
delivering coffee to a general so what
who are we what do we look like private
yeah private
yeah but what do we look like
a 16 year old guy who laid his words
oh yeah I mean we don't need a backstory
like physically like what is the what is
the model is it gonna be humanoider or a
simple shape uh humanoid I think of
course
humanoid so Tim wants to make a human
idea
hi
so we don't really have anything like
downhills and I think that I guess
you're right well but it could still be
abstract like isn't it it shouldn't be
like a realistic proportion no no no no
no like a big head or something yeah
cartoon yeah it's always fun I was
thinking I don't know what art style
exactly I had a pigeon because that's
kind of like a carrier you know oh yeah
of messages
that could be actually like a cool
so I guess it went really and the wings
being flat the Flappy Wings
but like I don't know I feel like
gameplay wise on the ground might be a
bit uh yeah I think I mean you could
always land
to fight some soldiers
I guess we'll need some guns as well
or like a little uh bayonet or something
it would be fun if there was uh at least
one cabin
Cannon
[Music]
a cannon like you mean on the ground or
uh like yeah that you could just shoot
what are we thinking or does it not
matter like is it World War one kind of
setting
I don't know if it matters
why not
um I think
uh it could be um one idea I had as well
is when you hit an enemy the blood
effect could be just like a bunch of red
cubes that just spill out yeah that
could be cool that'd be cool
uh and I think that's the style we
should kind of go with like almost like
voxely that's what I was kind of
thinking for like yeah okay okay well
okay so Foxy's the character would be
voxel so we said no to cubes and we went
with foxes oh
but still happens and we're making to
the complex
yeah voxley
R2D2 Australian emu War
yeah Peter have recently learned about
that
yeah I did Australian emu oh they're
trying again with Amy's in like the 30s
yeah I didn't even know that Australian
government sent in actual Soldiers with
guns to hunt down emus and the emus one
we don't talk about that
is Charlie coming to his like pretty
good track record of some things there
was a time when the queen sacked the
entire Australian government like
everybody just got laid off by the queen
she's like you guys aren't doing a good
enough job really yeah one time in the
70s that's funny
homing pigeons
um I know this is kind of like we're
still fleshing out the game but what
about the level what is it is it like a
mesh that's just one measure we make or
is it a tile generation I'm probably
honestly going to get like
Bing to
generate some AI concept art yeah just
to kind of get some ideas like that
could be cool I kind of want to do that
um but I kind of think we should maybe
do like procedural noise generation kind
of like you know
um that sounds like Peta yeah that
sounds like pain
um well just like basically for the
tiles you know so have like a pseudo
around the world
um kind of like how Minecraft is
generated but simple obviously
it would be a lot of fun to do that
um
because that way it's like it can be
almost roguelike element to it with like
the terrain is part of the obstacle to
overcome not just what's coming at you
but the terrain as well like every time
you drop into a new place and so I think
replayability would be good in that
level or the alternative is I make like
just one static mesh or whatever and
that's what you play every time
uh
so absolutely I think sooner random
level generation would be cool so with
tiles as well maybe yeah
and we can try out hexagonal tiles
oh really
that's what you wanted yeah you don't
have to do that but well I mean we look
we thought you wanted I I know where I
can find like the equation for
positioning hexagons in a effective way
grid that makes sense like okay yeah
but it's
it's more annoying than just a normal
pile grid
so okay I don't know if it necessarily
is because
I just feel like
it's just like every second row is at an
offset and that's all I think that's of
like point five basically yeah if you
have everything yeah
a lot of ways of doing it
um
but I think I know a video that actually
just covers it no but like because it's
it because it's hex it's not like it's
octagons or anything like it fits in
perfectly like
all it is is why why don't I do that
I mean you can why don't I do that
um just for Fine Art like that can be my
programming thing that I do
like yeah because I feel like I did the
I did the generation for Forest
so
but also I don't I don't want the
movement to be tar based
like No it should just be smooth yeah
the world should just be made from tiles
yeah
that is still like Smooth movement
and maybe to make people feel better at
the very beginning of the game you get
to choose if you are delivering coffee
or tea
because I feel like I feel like that
would be very easy to set up either way
and like these Brits well yeah and then
the the difference is like maybe in the
model of the cup there's like a little
tea bag hanging out for the tea version
yeah
we could do that
all right well I it sounds like my task
is pretty clear I'm gonna get I'm gonna
first of all get the right branch of
Hazel which I don't think I have at the
moment and then I'm just gonna start
putting together a hexagonal
world
um yeah and then my basically create
World War One elements in a voxley style
basically right
yeah
um and then are we having humanoid
enemies as well
I guess so well
I don't know like I just the reason why
I don't like human or doing humanoids is
like I feel like it's not
well no I mean if you make them really
abstract it just feel it feels like a
lot of work with the animation since you
know the skeletons and it can be just
simple yeah
a lot of times
the enemies of the players model why
don't you just make it a head and then
legs head and legs
and then like the gun is just floating
like in Rayman or something you know
sure that might be better so you have
that's kind of enemies
yeah everyone I think it's cute if you
just have like a round ball for the head
there's textured and might have some
hair or whatever you know some extra
model or whatever on it but then it's
just like running around on legs okay
and the legs are animated okay yeah
that's kind of that's kind of cool but
the head is going to be voxely as well
though right yeah no no no make the head
not voxley I don't yeah I don't think
everything should be like voxley and
square okay
I think but the environment like trees
and stuff like that will do boxing
yeah I don't know but like when when I
was thinking of voxley I was really just
thinking of the kind of particles but
like yeah you can
you can play around with that I guess I
don't know
okay cool well I guess I'm starting on
that then yep yeah and I'll probably
just start doing the player movement and
Camera controller
uh yes yep
are we so are we doing like
uh
basically the camera is kind of orbiting
the player like and you can control the
camera with the mouse yeah or
I think so okay well like click click
and drag nah you know what we could just
not no no no no wait I think well I was
thinking it's kind of like almost like
picture a third person camera but it's
locked so that you can only rotate that
you can only orbit around the play you
can't get like you can't tilt it
basically or you can't pitch it
um and also and it just moves in the
direction you're facing that's what I
was initially thinking
but I actually think it might kind of be
cool if it was just like no mouse at all
and it was just like wasd you know and
then the arrow keys the left and right
arrow keys all but the camera
you know what I mean so it's like you
you move with wasd so you can still
strafe and walk backwards and stuff but
then if like if you want to move the if
you want to tilt the world
then you can use like the arrow keys and
that way it's just like no mouse at all
which is actually good because the QA
computer doesn't have a mouse at the
moment
okay but you have a spare Mouse just
laying there do I yeah where when you
bought this mouse you bought two
I'll bring you the box
there's no way I have I just have like a
yellow
brain I don't think I do Tim why would I
have a Logitech oh I think is it no I
think I'm pretty sure I took it home I
want it for home yeah
so do we want the camera to like be kind
of pitching down a bit by default so
like well you kind of like dichotomy a
little bit but I'm still almost
picturing almost top down you know in
the sense that it's kind of like
dichotomy is the angle
some people complain about that hey
I don't know like people are the camera
yeah that it's like it's a bit difficult
to control because you're like on an
Offset you know
technically going down but that's not
really going to be a problem if you can
rotate the camera oh yeah if you can
rotate the camera then no
it's yeah right
are we distance wise are we having the
same distance from the player
because that's important to me on in
terms of how much detail I'm going to
put into the textures how much is
actually going to be because I spend a
lot of the time a lot of time on
texturing I think I don't know like as
the aesthetic wise I kind of like the
idea of it looking like dichotomy but
maybe
a bit more pixelated and you know what I
mean like kind of like what I was
picturing where it's almost looks like
it's down sampled but it's the lighting
is smooth
okay so maybe almost like Minecraft
textures Minecraft textures yeah maybe a
little higher as we can do we can
probably just do the same distance from
like the player though
Peter is asking because he's about to
control C control V that caught on the
camera
it should be dead easy to get it to work
I think because it's just it's really
it's really simple rotation around yeah
this scent around the player basically
yeah
um and that's it and then other than
that it's basically like dichotomy
camera yeah
I don't know yeah like play maybe make
The Mouse and the arrow keys I don't
know like this whole Arrow key thing
like I just feel like that might just
mean it's a bit more casual you know I
just feel like
because otherwise like if you're in a
laptop in bed or something and it's like
with a mouse it's annoying you know but
if you've got the arrow keys it's like
it's still playable that's kind of what
I was picturing
but you can you can try it with the
mouse you can try it with not the mouse
and I also if we do it with the mouse we
have to deal with mouse sensitivity
which as you know for forest was a
nightmare oh yeah
we could also make this work really
nicely with a controller because you'd
have just the right time stick yeah the
controllers work on Linux
uh there is a way of getting them to
work I think Xbox controllers are
slightly annoying to make them work yeah
because they're Microsoft glfw dlfw
might handle it it should it does I'm
surprised that I'd be surprised if it
didn't work but it's Linux so I have to
ask all right
what is the game what are you doing well
for now we're just fleshing out a cute
little player character moving around a
hexagonal world with Peter's camera
that's step one yeah and then I'm hoping
the game will just ride itself okay cool
yeah
so try and maybe run it through if you
go to Bing like you can just for free
generate as many AI images as you want
okay so maybe explore that with some
concept art like just to get it and I
just idea is flying okay I'll uh send
some screenshots
cool yeah all right oh and Peter can you
please let me know like oh it says the
LD 53 fix Branch right yes and how did
you set up the repository for the game
yep okay
beautiful in the Discord all right
cool all right well I guess I'll hang up
on the call but call back if anything
all right see ya cool bye see ya
okie dokie
okay
um
someone responded to the Twitter post
announcing this video and said how did
the good theme win
people
are the worst
hey um any idea where the Skin's still
doesn't work oh it doesn't work if
I don't know right
did you not try to think about that
maybe nobody just said anything about
power right oh yeah
[Music]
all right
back on this mic
um so yeah
as you may have heard
I will be working on a hexagonal
grid world
which I don't think I've ever done
before
but
it's uh
I want to go back to a wider lens
[Music]
so
um let's see
so basically
uh we're going to
pull
now let me quickly just
do a little something
some housekeeping
[Music]
all right
um
so what I believe has happened is Peter
has set up
some repositories he's already made a
repository of the game which is good
so that means we can just
quick I can just pull some stuff and
I'll share my screen in a minute
[Music]
foreign
we'll get Peter to make the project and
then I'm going to or I'm in the meantime
Paul Hazel because Hazel is a little
like I don't have the right branch
[Music]
so let's just get this sorted
organized
the new Fork workspace called ld53
this guy
and then I guess it's here
[Music]
competitors forgot to push over
um
yeah I think I'll just I don't want to
clone Hazel entirely because I'll take
[Music]
do I have anything in
do I have anything
[Music]
yeah not really okay good that means
like I'll just use this
um
I'll just switch this to ld53 fix
just make sure I have the latest
okay
so that's done
um
okay
okay make sure that's all good to go
so this is yeah this is using my new
rounder
it's good exciting we get to kind of
check it out is the music really too
loud
I think I'm just quiet
turn myself up a bit this should be
better
there's a fine line because on this
thing on this interface it's like the
last
five percent is like the old gain is
like the most
the that makes really the biggest
difference because they can't like the
game is not that
the preamps on the actual uh
interface aren't that bad I am using a
cloud lifter though but still
all right
um
let's open up Hazel and yeah Peter seti
he had that project didn't he
why am I on detached head oh because it
was completely empty so let me check
this out then
right
why is it not uh look at here
I think Fox a little bit confused unless
for his tough Fork
okay good
so basically what I should be able to do
let's do a release build
of Hazel I'm actually going to turn
Vulcan validation on though
I actually might already be
no let's turn it on and release as well
uh just because this and I'll do a clean
build just because this is a um
this is my new renderer as I mentioned
and there are some
they're possibly some things to iron out
okay I'll turn it down the gain a little
bit
maybe even a little bit more
that was so minor it's like either red
or it's like green not even yellow so
I'll try
and find maybe this is yeah this might
be better
get client is called Fork
mm-hmm
[Music]
foreign
although we could probably just use
the LD
like we've got one for item Day game
that's right like what else would that
be used for
yeah let's just use LD games
yeah before special
uh all right let's see if this works oh
I need to make sure actually that my
environment variables
set
yeah they are
and I'm going to have to set up my
shortcuts a little bit because
uh they're very
on set I opted a visual studio and
somehow cleared all my shortcuts
end of socks
okay so I'm kind of set up now
generate the projects for
um the game and this is the game
solution as well so I got the game
solution set up
I've got my Hazel solution set up and
pinned to the quick launch very
organized today
uh
these are already a script dummy.cs
that's just like the new project
workflow I guess um probably made that
all right let's launch Hazel
how's it already happened oh that's
that's a different one let's dichotomy
all right
um so if I do open projects
three
okay so this is it this is the new
project
okay
hexagonal
stop
um
maybe let's get rid of this for now
so I think hexagons like shouldn't be
that difficult I've never done them
before I'm gonna not like I'm gonna just
I feel like it should be dead simple
though to do hexagonal tiles to be
completely honest like I'd be very
surprised if there's a weirdo thing with
it because it just seems so simple
um but
basically like what I'm thinking right
is
um
you know like a hexagon looks like this
right let me draw it better
not ideal but
wait
determined
that first one's lame but yeah so the
thing is if you want to fit another
hexagon into here
um
what seems to be the thing
with these is that
is that basically
this row is the offset row so there's
basically it like because these stack
obviously like if I keep using different
colors
you can see that vertically it just
Stacks perfectly
unless you I guess you could rotate and
make this be horizontal if you wanted to
but vertically they stack perfectly but
then what you do have oh no how do I get
rid of that
oh great oh for one time for my whole
drawer
maybe there was a way to get rid of it
but anyway the point is like you know
vertically they stack perfectly right
but then if you want to
it's when you go kind of horizontal that
you have one of two rows and you can see
that basically one of the rows on it
like if these are if this diameter I
guess is one then
uh
what happens is this kind of odd row so
if this is like Roman x0 this is one
this is two the odd rows basically are
vertically
offset
but then again
yeah well they're vertically offset
basically by 0.5 right because that's
0.5 if that's if this is one so it's
kind of origin if it's the middle that
you're kind of going from is offset by
that amount and then
and that's kind of that that column
sorry so these are the rows and these
are the columns
um and then obviously the the road the
rows themselves are fine but there's
just that kind of
row I guess has a different y origin so
if if you start
if this is like let's just say this is
the the top of the world and one the
bottom would be zero but whatever the
top zero this is at 0.5 then that means
these rows are at one they're at one two
three and these are at 0.5 1.52 that's
really it and then as far as obviously
horizontal goes it's just normal like
this is one this is two this is three
this is four so like I think it's really
really simple
like I don't think there'd be any
problem really with it so what we're
going to do is we're going to go to
blender
and I'm basically going to probably
start by so I'll I'll start by just
making a hexagon
which I don't know how to do that
um is there a
yeah what's the is there an actual
preset or
no oh yes that's a good idea
let's make a
triangle fan
was it yeah six perfect
and the depth is that
okay so we could just be easy here uh I
guess 0.5 is what we'd want though for
the radius
so 0.5 so it's one by one is kind of
what we're looking at right
that looks kind of
no that's correct oh my gosh okay I got
it back but I didn't really
ah Blanda you're annoying sometimes
it's a good thing to remember with my
settings all right so that's kind of
yeah that's what I wanted so this is my
hexagon
I'm gonna rename it even
um so let's export that as a gltf we can
just do it
but binary
oh I'm Tim yeah what
um meshes in the meshes folder
because
uh yeah sure I just mean like because
you usually make a folder called models
and then I never know which one because
we also have the mattress folder
oh so you have a source versus ah no I
just make a folder in meshes called
Source that's what I should do as well
okay so let's get that asset into Hazel
it should already be here
uh and let's make I guess we should make
a scene
well we already have my insane that's
our default one
sure I'll keep that
um
so let's drag in that hexagon
static mesh create
uh I don't even know what material I set
it up with but this Skylight is just
very bright that's nice all reflective
okay so here we have
power guy
um
so here's what we're gonna do we're
going to make a grid of these basically
and I think what I will do is let's just
create like some materials because I
want to differentiate
uh
hexagon red
blue
I guess I should do M underscore hexagon
Orange let's do that
I'll do it I'm underscore for material
so
um let's say this guy's blue
so we'll make the color
be like a nice blue
ah
first crash
this is map nice memory being freed
that sounds like a bug that I fixed
already
I can check easily
no I did
ah well I whatever if this keeps
happening I'm gonna just run it with um
address sanitizer but
that kind of sucks yeah it's when it's
basically when something to do with
material assets I think I like I feel
like I have seen that before
okay
yeah this is not the most stable Branch
unfortunately so we have an auto save
that's the wrong project I'll probably
tell it to open this
uh I didn't save it all did I oh and
auto why is auto Savvy not on let's make
Auto saving on
how do I do that
oh that's in the config
I don't think there's a UI for that all
right
um it's okay we didn't really lose much
work because the assets obviously are
real so you can't play with that too
much okay well I might repo that crash
later and fix it if I feel like it okay
um and then the meshes that I made this
is it so we basically just made that we
assigned blue to it didn't we oops here
so that's like blue
let's duplicate that let's move it by
like one right
huh
that's weird
what
why is that not
one
so a radius of 0.5 that's to where
exactly
because I think what's happened is that
this is not quite
the right size
that's 0.87
because I'm guessing
that is one
so
I kind of want it to be
one on this axis though
which is fun
what would that mean like if I wanted
what would this radius need to be
I guess you could work it out using the
angle right
because like whatever angle that is I
can probably work it out
which is a yeah 60 60 degrees right 60
degrees sounds right I think it's 60
degrees So based on 60 degrees what
would I need this to be well what would
I need what would if I if this was one
then what would that be
um
that
and then this and what would this be
though one side of it
do I know that but that would also grow
so I feel like that's annoying right
or is that now because that's it because
that's obviously not quiet but
that wouldn't be right
this is 0.5 though
so one side of its 0.5
what's the math for this
we can't just use pythag for this camera
because we don't know this
or do we know that
people saying radius 0.577 how did you
find that out though what's the
what's the formula
cosine of 60.
is 1 over X
okay yeah X is one over cosine of 60 I
think
isn't it one two square root three is
the center length 36.90 I don't remember
thank you
well we could we could just okay so
cosine of 60
more in degrees yep
is 0.5
and 1 divided by 0.5 is not
correct so
I'll start saying sine of 60. I don't
remember this
oh yeah of course yeah you can find the
length by it's like the angle uh Mana
this is like high school math is coming
back to me a little bit I haven't used
this stuff in a while though even though
it's pretty basic trick
um
[Music]
now I'm trying to say I'm not trying to
find the height I'm trying to basically
say that if this needs to be
if this is a length of one
well whatever you know what I only have
time for this
um someone said
someone said 1.149 so I want to try that
and that's not the that's the that's the
that's what that has to be so it has to
be half of that
right
so five seven four five apparently
which sounds like it could work
yeah
that does look a little bit off
it might not be though yeah I think it's
just what I've done
yeah that's that's probably good enough
right
[Music]
maybe I'll round it up a little bit so
it's a bit intersecting should I do that
or whatever I guess you could have a
microscopic gap on the other hand
I don't know
okay let's try this
hexagons ended up being difficult just
because of this
Hazel
uh
why does nothing work
come on
okay I to be fair though I haven't tried
reloading meshes with the new renderer
at all that's something that I
definitely should have done
so the exact is one divided by square
root of three okay sure
gotta get it to not open dichotomy every
time
uh and also let's quickly go to Ireland
and save the scene again I don't need to
stop doing that start up saying main
scene
uh 0.3 was it
hexagon oops
so that now should be correct I think
let's give it the blue thing and let's
save this time okay I've saved guys
don't worry
um so now
if I duplicate that and make it one that
should be more or less correct
I mean see this one I mean though
because you have that Gap
it's kind of like it kind of looks cool
though doesn't it it's like a little
black outline I mean the problem is as
you zoom out it looks like garbage
potentially now um the other thing is we
could turn on and we probably will turn
on
um dichotomies
Edge Shader because we kind of kind of
liked I think we want that aesthetic for
the game so
um
where do we
where do we create the scene around draw
foreign
oh
no I think the same no actually what
uh we just we don't we it's just so we
stick with defaults I think which is a
little bit annoying
for this version I guess
um but where do we create the scene
renderer
so here it is
and I guess
yeah it's a default specification we
could just for this Branch obviously
change the default specification so we
could be like let's do the edge outline
effects
it's a bit annoying because it's in a
head of file obviously uh
I could just make the override in the
Constructor but whatever because
obviously this is like this branch is
kind of becoming
the um
this branch is kind of becoming like the
blood and 53 branch of Hazel because we
might need to modify the engine a bit
anyway so
and I gotta stop it from doing that let
me just do that now
I'm gonna get it to load the right thing
okay and that's just for release
now it should load the right project and
the right scene yeah
all right
um
oh my agile lines aren't here though
what
why not
that's a little weird
should be there oh the Shader
yeah because that's a manual switch
unfortunately I think
actually should it even be
um but that's the compositing Shader
probably isn't just compositing yeah
it's this
just do that
surprised I didn't crash whatever there
you go
so that's it yeah see it's a bit weird
because they're so close together we
could deliberately move them a little
bit apart like you know
like if we make if we change the size of
the mesh so that they're like a little
bit apart like that that could actually
look cool
you know because you kind of have gaps
between them
and I don't really have to do that
obviously and I could just scale it here
I don't have to change the mesh if I
don't want to
but I think hexagons are kind of cool to
be completely honest
yeah maybe even like a bigger Gap
no that's probably too big
okay in that case let me just eyeball it
a bit
um let's
I'm sure Hazel will crash if I try
reloading again but let's try to make a
hexagon again
so this was five seven four five let's
make it like five five
[Music]
I will re-export that it's really
annoying if I can't hot reload though
and I don't seem to be able to
yeah
I could just fix this probably
it's a submit resource free though but
why is it still in use it should have
reloaded it
that's so strange it's the index buffer
as well because by by now it shouldn't
be in use anymore
difficult to fix now I think
it might not have been a crash actually
it might have just been a welcome
validation error that's but that does
look like it might be a crush all right
so
if we now set this to be one this is the
distance
are we happy with that that looks kind
of cool I think yeah whatever I'll stick
with that for now
um now that's that's one aspect of it
right so let's go ahead and make this
guy have a different material
uh which we haven't set up yet so let's
make that and this was also a crash so
we have to be somewhat careful
almost doesn't look orange enough
ah we need to use correct colors we're
not in we're in linear color space I
think
aren't we we're about to find out
[Music]
uh maybe not
why are we so we're taking this too
linear
is this what we did in the economy
I forgot what we did specifically in
dichotomy
um let me see if I can find out
[Music]
if this is Hazel and dichotomy
maybe at least
because I feel like yeah maybe that
didn't get matched
it looks the same
but I'm not 100 sure if that's that that
is dichotomy so that is doing what it
should be doing
like with the oh that was with the
textures anyway actually so I think I'm
talking about the wrong thing
and as long as we're gamma correcting
which we would be
yeah I think that's that's different
yeah so why I don't know why that
doesn't look orange
and I'm scared to push it too much it
could be the roughness as well
all right whatever
um that'll be our orange uh and then
let's duplicate this guy
and let's make it we'll give him red
which isn't actually set yet
and then let's move yeah that doesn't
seem right well I think we're in linear
color space because that's not saturated
enough we'll fix that later though um
okay so yeah and so if I move him
basically one on Zed
yeah see that doesn't quite line up to
that
so they have to be at a different okay
but if we do that but then we do because
this is a one right if we do 0.5
yeah see this is not very uh
I was hoping it would be more
correct
but it's not really
because it would need to be like that
basically
which is okay like as long as this is
constant which it would be and then you
know this we can duplicate and make uh
like 1.5 right
and that would be perfect
like a green one as well maybe
thank you Chris for the five dollars
thanks for the table plus series it
helped me a lot with programming in
general you're welcome glad to help
uh okay oh oops I moved that a bit
uh hey young quick question yeah uh
Peter sent it in
absolutely I think well try not to
parent it because other if you do the
parenting thing like you can't really do
any animation or effects because it's
always like gonna be relative to the
player you want it to be a free camera
that just always use the player as the
target
because otherwise you can't really do
anything it's like very not flexible to
do it that way
um Okay so
yeah so that's fine then and 0.85 is the
Zed well that's I arbitrarily picked
that but that looks pretty much perfect
so then that means if I do if I uh so
0.85 times 2 is 1.7 so if I duplicate
let's just say this one
what I have to set it to 1.7
yeah
so basically what we've discovered let
me
is uh X the distance
is just one and then 0.5
uh
odd rows
why this or Z disc is
0.85 per row
and that's it
sounds at 0.86
sure I don't really care
yeah I guess
to be more exact
ly okay cool
um
so that's probably all we really need uh
uh so that's this is our Orange
let's just do hexagon Orange
have gone red
another orange one
oh the blue one I almost forgot about
the blue one okay so now what we're
going to do is we're going to make a
folder called prefabs
I'll make a follow within that called
hexagons
and we're going to make prefabs out of
all of these
and we can always update them so it's a
big deal but basically I'll just drag
all these in
and now we have the Mr prefabs so I can
delete all of these
should obviously be
ER correct
oh no I messed that up I should have
made them have
the transform I guess it doesn't matter
actually what that transform is because
we'll set it when we instantiate it okay
sure so
let's make a empty entity which I
already have one call it like level
generator
make it a underscore level generator
um okay and let's uh save
um we can build this whatever you
haven't built a dll yet
you better now no
manually
because I've built in the first place
yep there it is that's how dummy so
let's rename this dummy to be
level generator
um we'll add some public prefabs so
public prefab
I guess we can just do hexagons
can we we can probably do an array of
profiles right
I might have to tell it how many we want
okay so we'll do like four
actually never used arrays like that
like
like this for prefabs inside the editor
so hopefully this works all right so
basically we should have all the
hexagons here now so let me just try and
go like I still don't quite trust this
so let's just do four each prefab
p in hexagons let's just do instantiate
P let's just do that see if we can play
um and there you go all right we don't
actually have a camera which is why that
was being a bit weird
but we can do one for a few now thanks
to Tim so let's maybe just do that for
now
that'll be our camera so we'll create a
camera from View
um wait does that oh I'm in the camera
so is this
yeah because you can hit alt C and Hazel
and then you can you're in play mode but
you can use the editor camera which is
quite nice
all right
because then you can just hit play and
yeah so you can see it's instantiating
them great okay now we need to actually
saturate them properly so let's make
some kind of map size so let's do
bro what are you doing trying to print
my code
uh private in uh let's just do map width
sure uh
I don't know like
332 by 32 for now
whatever
um
now we're going to go through
this so y equals
care
that
now the uh the position here which will
be a vector three
is going to be
um
I guess we'll try and Center it will we
so we'll try and I mean no we don't have
to though we could just go positive X
and positive y so this will basically be
oh but yeah it's gonna matter what role
it is so
let's do
um ball odd equals x mod 2 equals zero
that's actually even but
sure so X12 equals zero so we'll
basically be like it's going to be so X
like what if we say where are my notes
X this is one 0.5 for odd rows so it's
just going to be X
it's gonna be X
but
times we can do even
one
otherwise 0.5
which we should really use floats at
this point
right that's what I want probably and
then Z distance is so Y is zero is that
is 0.86 per row
Ah that's up
yeah right
so let's talk about
um which I guess I'll rename to Zed
that might work and then let's just do
hexagons we'll do
hazel.random dot hence
well apparently all we can do is u164t
beautiful wait can I do range but that's
all fancy yeah okay so let's do zero two
this include three or four or whatever
um and then translation so let's go with
this function
because is this inclusive or not
I don't know
no I guess so
oh but we don't want it yeah so zero
three that's perfect well and it'll be
hexagon start
length months one but yeah
okay let's try this
okay that did not quite work
at all
what did I do wrong
foreign
[Music]
but obviously plus one not just by
itself yeah that's dumb so
um
so
yeah because it has to take into account
the even right
well you know what
probably wouldn't be the worst thing in
the world to just have the Zed here
like you could just do Z position
yeah in fact I guess you could even do
you could just pop the translation out
here
because it's going to be constant anyway
and we could just say the translation
dot Zed
ah but also I did X mod 2 I should have
done
because X is the column
right I'm going crazy with this stuff
but I think I'm right
um
because that wouldn't work anyway would
it
or whatever
or maybe it would no maybe maybe I just
I don't know actually I don't know what
I'm talking about but let's just write
that
yeah that's still not quite right
yeah no I think I know why that's
because I'm being stupid but yeah
um okay so basically we would do this up
here and then we would do translation.z
basically uh plus equals right so we'll
move it by an amount here and if it's an
even row
and we might do this afterwards
but if it's even
we basically add one otherwise we add
0.5 if it's odd that's what I was
thinking
um and then for the X
that's just going to be or is that's the
X oh no no I'm just I've messed this up
I think no no because that because this
is X
wait but doesn't make sense that's the X
translation what am I doing
no I think ah my notes were wrong
hold your horses everyone because I was
thinking that was it it's not
or is it
okay let's just look at this quickly um
not this uh what was my original layout
Okay so
this is always one
it's if we go up
and this is always one so X is always
one
so we know that X is always one so this
is really just X
always
what's different is how much do we go up
by
oh but it's at an offset that's why so
if yeah so if it's an even row we have
no offset it's just X otherwise
um let's just do float X position equals
so if there's even it's just X if it's
odd it's X Plus 0.5 that's the offset I
was talking about
so that's done that's easy and then for
the Zed it's just a multiple of 0.86
right
so that's done as well so actually I
think it's just this
is it not no it's not
why is this so difficult
[Music]
what
that should work I feel
and also it's clearly non-inclusive
because I'm not seeing any red ones
and red was the last one yeah
so
let's get rid of this
oh this is Zed oh my goodness me
this is just crazy
yeah that's there we go
I just kept getting like because I I
used rose with terminology I didn't use
columns at all I just kept I kept
confusing my x and z
that's all right beautiful hey Tim check
it out
hexagonal period and that's and there's
a little yeah there's also a little gap
between them which kind of looks cool I
think
and that's just that's randomly
generated
from four prefabs
that's awesome
so how are you doing I guess I'll send
this
hazel.com all right well it's just
generating rat like it's random in the
sense that
no well no it's just laying out a grid
of them but it's choosing the color just
by running around me during another from
zero to four or zero three or whatever
I'll send this into the into the Peter
chat
uh the Discord which is gone
and bring my Discord up
why did that disappear
yeah into LD
anyway where hexagon's not that easy
apart from the fact that I was being
stupid for ages yes of course it's
instanced is Hazel a zed forward engine
I don't know oh is that forward
um
no it would yes Zed is forward but I
don't know if it's negative is that a
positive set
sounds like I should know this
okay so yeah pretty cool we have our
little World
um
yeah so Tim yeah you're not working on
world tiles are you
yeah because I was just thinking that
like
we could probably just
you know like you could so if you take a
look at this right I don't know what
size it would be like I guess maybe
about this would be okay like I said it
doesn't have to be too zoomed out you
know like this is fine like being this
close to it well you know because at
this point it's just like how big are
the hexagons that's what we're talking
yeah right so if they're like because
well they're they're about one meter
like from here to here is a bit more
than one meter I think but from here to
here is one meter right so they're kind
of like one meter
apart and obviously if the player is
about a one meter he'll kind of stand
probably on this
so that's kind of big like but I can
easily make them bigger obviously by
just scaling them up but
my point I guess was that you could have
like you know if it's a Sandy landscape
right because I'm maybe there's like a
desert or something and this war zone
you could just have like a tile that you
could have a selection of five tiles
that's kind of Sandy and it's got dots
and stuff on it turned to get sound one
of them might have a cactus on them even
yeah because it's a model is so you can
add anything it doesn't have to be just
textured flat yeah it could be any model
but it has to be conformant to this so
what I'll do is I'll send you this send
me this this is like the base and then
you can because it's unscaled now right
yeah yeah oh but then yeah yeah I'll
leave it like this and then obviously
you know if we wanted to we could just
scale it up
maybe maybe we should just flat out
double them it's it's easy to do that
like obviously I'll just double the math
because there's no scale at the moment
but you know if there was
then it would just be
double the math basically
so or even you could do translation
times equal scale so
um I think basically if I
you can instantiate it with the skill
yeah yeah
no well I'm not gonna use yeah I'm not
gonna use scale if I just like do two
two
and then apply that I I'm just curious
I'll have to restart Hazel Hazel so
annoy it doesn't reload I think my new
render is a bit broken it doesn't reload
assets but actually I haven't determined
if that's actually a real crash or it's
a validation area
um but if I try that yeah that did not
Why didn't it work you stupid thing I'm
such a bad programmer today
um
oh because this scale's still one maybe
I'm not that bad
all right
oh look at that shadow map
but yeah so that's like two by two now
so if we have a uh one by one Cube for
reference which does this work oh it
does yeah I'm impressed
the game
where's my Cube though from the
underground yeah
okay yeah so that's the side that's one
by one that's that's pretty decent I
think right yeah
if that's one by one
positive
yeah that's pretty good yeah that looks
cool we're not conforming the movement
no I don't know it's it'll be smooth
let's add a directional light
that
if you open My Stream I guess like
that's what I have
what the heck I added I added a
directional light oh we already had one
I was I was gonna say why
is that weird but yeah I don't actually
see any Shadows oh
no it's because I think this is this
could be dichotomy Shadows
no they're just like the Cascades
tightened or something
what that's weird yeah what were we
saying
um the player
why does my Discord keep disappearing
yeah like it's not no no no
that's not it
here it is
it too late to not to love it
uh oh Peter tried calling me I'm on
another step so it drags on him anyway
oh this is the player concept I think
it's pretty cool yeah
Bob I want the ball
specifically yeah I want it to be round
because remember no cubes that's what we
said
well
well not let's do something round it
doesn't have to be an exact sphere you
could like sculpt it a little bit but I
feel like that would be nicer
and it has to be way bigger this Cube
like you know because it has to look
cute
yeah well it's uh
for stream for reference this is what
Tim's talking about
that's what we were talking about anyway
all the mushrooms
how do I get to your stream
but yeah
this yeah yeah I think it's gonna look
pretty easy
I don't know I feel like I would have I
feel like this would have been better
yeah yeah
I don't know
this just doesn't seem like a character
like a character no I know it's pretty
no but I think like with this face plus
animation maybe because I just think
like
well I don't know I think like animating
for example like a side to side run like
this yeah it's gonna be more obvious
with a model like this versus like a
sphere that's around anyway yeah that's
why I think like for animation
it's gonna be better plus like I think
this has the potential wind direction to
look better because if that's just the
balls but you can you can texture it I'm
not saying just a flat ball with no
texture no but like not just a flat ball
but like a hat you know like that kind
of stuff yeah
what's the difference like
anything you can do on this you can do
on a ball yeah it's just adding a little
bit of like I don't know because
everything is
rigid and everything has lines and it's
just like I just feel like if it was
you know just to mix up the geometry a
little bit have something actually
smooth and round because that's what I
like that's why I almost don't
it's like breaking away
well we can always probably change it
but like
don't don't go too into it like don't do
animation yet yeah let's just try and do
some Concepts like put it into the scene
basically and see what it looks like
yes it's on Studio Channel ld53
someone said why don't you make the
character out of hexagonal prisms
no yeah I don't know
okay
oh
um
yeah let's figure out why the lighting
is like not working or whatever
um
[Music]
doesn't work either
yeah but this the Shadows are not uh
working okay
that's so strange
yeah so we should have four Shadow
Cascades apparently
what could I have done to break them I'm
pretty sure I tested them before
started we might have to bust out like
around the dock or something and see
[Music]
I just want to actually make sure that
we have the right amount of Cascades and
stuff
you might not be able to though
what
is
I want to do a debug build
well
is this still doing stuff properly
yeah four Cascades yeah
foreign
[Music]
light so it doesn't have a position
um
yeah let's uh use rounder dock
foreign
oh now it's here what that's weird all
right anyway
um so let's uh do a little capture and
run it off
see what's going on
well we are definitely doing the passes
oh look
wait what
they do make it usually relevant
now that is weird
borrow something is really weird here
that's not getting fit
oh no it's not
whoops that's I thought that was all the
Cascades no no so this is actually
correct that's fine
so then
these are the draw calls I thought they
were the different Cascades and I'm like
what
but no these are the draw poles and
there's the cube at the very end
um
yeah like that seems fine I'm so that
render's fine so what is just the
compositing
geometry pass
oh look at this look at how ugly this
looks before any
like
before anything
and this is with lighting
that's like the clear color
and you can see how also Hazel's uh like
it's rejecting pixels that are obscured
so it's not wasting time calculating
pixels that are not done which is pretty
cool
foreign
and oh we have a dynamic mesh no that's
just a
um all right well
that obviously should have shadows and
it does not so
take a look at
some of the stuff we have here
sees
yeah I mean it all looks pretty good
I don't know what this is though
finding set one binding seven and eight
the uniform boss apparently these are
all present right
Shadow Cascades
there's a spot Shadow map just bought
Shadow Maps what
I feel like this is weird because I'm
pretty sure I tested this and it's not
it's not which one what is this
res 2105
oh here it is Shadow Cascades
well that's weird isn't it
this is just told you this is just all
incorrect
the death is all one
what
so what the resources and being found
correctly
but this obviously worked before
I just want to try a spotlight quickly
what
that is bizarre
color pick is broken
everything's terrible
that's my spotlight
foreign
cast Shadows
okay that's definitely a shadow
so
that's working
and it's handled in much the same way
so it's probably not the renderer or the
new renderer
or
something went wrong
yeah which crash
all right
very strange
like that should be fine basically
oh
[Music]
okay
it's annoying that I have to
yeah so why we learn we learned that
spotlights have shadows
and directional lights do not
and we don't know why
and also I can't like my color Pickers
don't work anymore
that's new
it's like it's like it's not catching
the event or whatever
oh man
I don't know how this could have
happened because
unless something broke it because this
was definitely working before let me
just try and like
maybe I'll recompile all the shaders or
something
just a little bit of a stretch but if we
just go to the shaders and delete
cache
then it will rebuild all the [__] where
you can buy all the shaders
this just never works for some reason
still no Shadows
now something something weird is going
on with the actual Shadow map
because this is it over here and it's
just empty
so like something is really weird
with that specific it looks like with a
specific resource
um
but the weird thing is I've obviously
seen this work like I've seen this
working since I
re
did the renderer so it's strange that
it's gone now
but it is weird that I can't see it
there let's go to the scene renderer
panel
because I should at least see it there
in the UI
uh physics captions panel
[Music]
okay so that accesses that and get tired
frame buffer get depth image
and the Cascade index so this doesn't
really matter it could be zero maybe
because one pass basically well
and then Cascade index Waters actually
do that yeah it looks at a particular
slice of it I guess
layout yeah
hmm
[Music]
foreign
so what's the target frame buffer here
we set it here pipelines back Target
frame but all right here it is so we
create it here and it's a existing image
of layers
[Music]
but where's it's cascaded depth image
yeah so here it is the shadow map frame
up a spec existing images cascaded depth
image
which is a layered image here
this per layer image views should be
there
blah blah
I mean that all looks like it should
work it's just what's weird is we don't
seem to be able to sample from it
foreign
into the geometry path as an input
it's just a regular image
right
so this image info get descriptor info
Vulcan
that obviously doesn't have anything to
do with the Pearl layer but we don't
want it to be a per layer though that's
the other thing right we kind of just
want it to be
yeah an array a sampler array which it
is oh you know what it might no no
surely not
because I did play yeah so this this is
what it should be it should just be a
sampler 2D array
because I was messing around with that
at some point but yeah
yeah
um
because get Larry interview is probably
not exactly used
anywhere
oh but the attachments
okay
because we create a separate frame yeah
that makes sense
but we'd be getting a validation error
if we were doing something very bad
right
but it still just seems like
for some reason like it maybe the image
view is weird because it just can't
what is the image here because it
doesn't seem to be able to read it
properly
right
it is coming up as an array
but it's so strange because it's like it
just looks empty though
like is that not the same resource 2105
like what are we writing to here
just it's just a central Cascades
yeah look here they are so this is the
complete thing so what is this then
what if it is just like
no I can't be there
what if I try this what if I like again
I'm 90 sure that I saw this working
which is why it's even stranger but what
if I instead of doing this right
what if I just do
um let's do
Cascade what was it cast
what was the name of that image
basically
cascaded depth image
which I don't think is available in that
scope but we'll make it available
am I sure is the same resource well I
don't see why it wouldn't be but like it
does seem like it's not
oh no no no I know exactly what this is
exactly what this is
um it's rare that I keep having to set
that
um it's yeah it's and that's explains
why I worked before as well it's because
um
whenever I wrote the renderer there's
two passes there's a there's a pass for
static measures and a pass for animated
meshes when it comes to the depth pass
and what happens is the static path is
the first and the animated one guess
what it does it clears the buffer
so the animated one needs to not clear
the buffer
is basically the the thing that it
should do so that should be pretty easy
to do
um
like all we should probably do is
so this is all fine it's just that the
directional Shadow pass anim thing that
takes in it probably doesn't create its
own frame buffer or do they both use the
same one yeah they both use the same one
so it is to create its own frame buffer
it's still with the same image right so
we're not actually creating more image
resources or whatever but this uh frame
buffer spec
needs to basically do clear color unload
or clear depth on load I guess is what
we want false
um and then we can just do true before
we do so it clears it for the static
pass and it doesn't clear it for the NM
pass and that should work
glad I caught that
yeah and it's happened that's happened
before like with other things that were
way easier to debug
hey look at that shadow wonderful all
right so if I hit play
we now have a shadow
and we can probably tighten the uh well
we will do that anyway we'll end up
tightening the shadow map and stuff like
later in the uh
later in the process
um and I really should Fade Out the
Shadows to not
because at the moment if it if it goes
out of like scope it just makes it black
but it should just make it not be a
shadow like hazel used to do it back in
the day
um but yeah
all right
okay good so that's fixed I should
probably push that to the engine
so
let's see if anyone else pushed anything
to the game
oh and I guess I don't need to do that
do I
was
a matter of fact so let's undo this
change
yeah so we did that that's what it was
make sure that works
is
okay
yeah that clearly works right
yeah
does it just not work from this camera
angle or that that's just because it's
perfectly the shadow right
um but I guess I should test that
we can just move the directional line
Shadows are fine all right excellent
that's good
um
so I will push that
okay no one has pushed anything here yet
um all right so I guess we can
Peter's working on the camera
I guess one thing that might be fun for
me to do is maybe write like a little
particle system like we had basically in
Forest I'm thinking
because in forests
um if you guys remember that
Academy award-winning game
um the uh when you shoot the enemies
like some
stuff would fall out from them
uh and I think that it might be nice
to
steal that basically
hopefully it will still work more or
less because obviously the uh
um
the thing has changed but I think it
should
um so and the reason why we want this is
for blood effects basically so I want to
be able to
um let me just do a really basic camera
now I know Peter's doing his own but
uh so this Cube will kind of be our
player for now
um can we just I'll get rid of the plane
let's Chuck in some Physics
so we'll add a rigid body
uh
okay good um and then let's grab the
prefabs
let's I guess add a rigid body
static pressure party
um
we could just use a box Collider
doesn't really matter
a mesh colliders don't work
like I said they don't show up
all right what
I added a box of glider here why is it
not showing up does it only do one oh
does it clear it
is that what happens does it also is it
also the same problem as
no
this just won't oh no well this might
just be too small yeah it is too small
like never mind
but the mesh collider not working it's
weird
that might be due to something yeah
uh where's that original body
we don't really need to do this but
um
yeah so we could just make like the
collider be
like really it doesn't matter too much
because you're not really going to be
able to probably fall we could make you
fall into things
like traps
remind me of dichotomy
we know that's one though
um and then the
forgot what we made the thing but
I don't know if that's actually a half
size but
1.1 sure
but it's thinner this way isn't it
anyway this really doesn't matter yeah
0.86 I think
all right that's not funny it's external
[Music]
um okay and then we can just update the
prefab now I can obviously uh copy this
is very useful
and a rigid body and aesthetic version
so let's
add a
a rigid body
box collider and I'll paste in the
params
update
Orange
paste
update red
I don't know if I ever need a richer
body
that's pretty cool now I did want to
make yeah a very basic camera in the
form of just uh let's attach the camera
to the player
reset the transform
let's drag it up
let's probably either rotate it
yeah I guess rotate it
and they're not tilts
pitch it down I need to
make it be further away
I just want to have like a little camera
[Music]
sure whatever okay
but the idea is um
now obviously you can see it kind of
follows the player
because it's parented which is not a
good way to do cameras but it's a good
way to quickly do that
um all right it's team streaming yes uh
I'll send his guys go and show his his
stream some love I will send his stream
Link in the description in a minute
I want you guys to go to a stream and
say hi and subscribe
foreign
Okay so
that's a hot looking lag Tim
I really was picturing just like a cot
like a cartoony really simple Style
but this is like full-on well I don't
know I just hope this will look good
with like the rest of the game because
if this is like really detailed and you
know what I mean realistic and then
yeah yeah I can see that yeah that's
kind of not yeah I don't know it looks
like a TV
is he supposed to be
detailed
that's kind of that's a Vibe that's a I
did a game jam and ran out of time and
bit off more than I can chew vibe
foreign
what's up Franco
let's see here so uh the particle system
and that should be easy enough
so we have one uh well this is the one
that we I have in Forest right uh this
is from forest I don't think we had one
we kind of yeah we didn't really have
one yeah so I'm just gonna copy this uh
here it is coming from
Forest
let's add a new item
particle system dot CS
namespace ld53 paste that Poppy in
um and does it compile almost Force Mode
is wrong because I think it's e-force
mode now
it's petery wrote the physics engine uh
so that's it that's that just compiles
basically now will it actually work I
don't know
um
particle order I guess that's like uh I
would like to order a package a particle
pack please that's funny
um but I think that's actually what it
is
okay anyway
um so let's
let's
uh
what is it gonna do though so a particle
has to be uh particle entity
oh no no that's what it's holding the
particle yeah so this is a prefab okay
that's fine so and then you do spawn
impact and then oh you can just give it
that okay so we just do that so
technically speaking what I could do is
I could say
um
if input Dot is key Crest let's just do
key code not Escape
key code like space or something
probably add a little like time a cool
down timer
maybe like point two
so
if we do that then let's we can just do
particle system apparently dot spawn
impact
so this will be our little blood thing
so we need a prefab for the particle
then a translational Direction and
impulse Force life count and life
variation okay so prefab will be our
blood particle which we'll make in a
minute translation
[Music]
um
let's do maybe the player
oh this is level generator it's a bit
weird but uh well
public entity player
so we'll do player basically dot I guess
translation uh direction will be player
Dot
well
no let's just make it like a new Vector
three
um
Maybe
and um
oh actually yeah let's just do
uh
uh we'll just do a random book three
whatever
the impulse force will be
somewhat random but at least one I guess
um
life will be
I guess we're gonna make that random as
well but at least like
maybe three seconds
so let's make this like times two maybe
at least at least two seconds
times up to five
um
count or
maybe like 15. let's just do 15.
um again then blood particle will be a
prefab
build that
okay so let's make a blood particle
prefab
um
what this has that bloodparkly up I'll
play okay so we'll drag down the player
that's the player thing now and now
we'll do a um
so this is basically just going to be
like a cube well I was picturing a cube
pretty tiny Cube
and obviously it has to be red because
it's full so
um
probably make a new material really
should put that into controls folder
um
particle blood
I typed in bloom instead of blood that's
funny
I'm the real nerd here
um red
it should be glossy glossy red
um
that's not like that I really I think I
will play with colors because I'm pretty
sure that uh we are not again in a
proper color space
okay
so if I hit space bar will anything
happen
no
now
that's a bit weird
that nothing happened don't do the same
thing
uh I mean is it trying to
Pawn anything
yeah it is
it's definitely trying to
well it's
yeah but oh but on the other hand are
they just maybe falling through the
world
no they're just not are they being
instantiated they're not being
instantiated oh no it's because I'm a
buffoon um it's because I think this
particle system actually obviously needs
to be updated and I'm not doing that LOL
okay so we'll pull um
particle
system dot on off day right
it's
oh this is an answer ah this wants to
exist in the world
I see okay fine we'll let you exist
script
damn we full-on crashed
that's a Peter crash
exactly
I couldn't find reginbot no I could find
the Roger body
Ah that's actually a good point I don't
think I met I think that's a static
rigid body maybe that's why it's upset
um because what is that blood particle I
didn't actually make the blood particle
um
it's got a box collider but that's just
natural I think
if I give it a dynamic rigid body which
is really what I wanted to do
and update it maybe it won't
cry there we go
it kind of makes me move because it
yeah they look kind of small Maybe
I feel like they shouldn't have an
outline effect on them maybe because
that's weird
um
and the the Collision layers definitely
shouldn't be where they are
so if we make a new new layer called
blood and collides with self is off
I'll just make alcohol particles
if I have to save the project or
whatever but
um
let's see where's my layer
layer particles
so that should probably be better and I
don't know maybe I will scale it up a
bit 0.1
but they probably shouldn't have an
outline effect and I don't have a way of
whoa
I've never seen this oh it's just not
set
but that is weird
I think that's a that's a bad thing
don't know what happened there to be
completely honest
so they shouldn't collide with
themselves anymore
and they they shrink after time as well
so that's my like blood
my blood particles
shrink half the time
it's kind of cool
can anyone tell me how his player member
in his particle got initialized
um yes I so I made the player be a
public entity right so it appears as a
field in the editor
and then we have obviously like inside
the script component
the player is a field here and then all
I did to get it to be here was I just
took the actual player entity right and
I dragged it down into here
um and that's it right so this can be
any entity in the scene
and you can either drag it or you can
select it and search it and you know
whatever
that's basically I think the same as
unit as Unity
okay
um
so yeah pretty cool got some particles
and now yeah the color space is really
annoying I think but
yeah I guess I also want them to be kind
of bright and also not um
I don't know if it should shrink because
that was what we did in um
uh Forest but we could just like
you know have them not shrink
so you can see that
um
the scale
the scale is basically dependent on the
lifetime so if we just don't do that
then they won't
you know they won't scale down they'll
just disappear after a while when they
get destroyed
um
there should be a scale variation as
well I think
that would be good for blood
specifically
so
what's the scale here
yes the scale I think it just takes from
the particle entity
or does it no pizza particles do have a
scale though
yeah it's it's basically hard-coded
um
which shouldn't really be the case I
mean there is like a there is variation
but let's make maybe let's make it more
varied so we'll do
so that'll be basically the minimum
scale and then we'll go up to
basically like three times the scale
that you've asked for how about that
they all look the same size wonderful
that's a bit weird
yeah oh no actually I mean that that
three times the scale no that's more
than three dollar scale your eyes for
that's no no it's not oh but you're
adding it
so that actually would be huge so I
don't know why that didn't work
because that particle is being set oh
because we're not setting scale sorry so
this should actually I shouldn't have
commented that out it should be this
is kind of what I meant to use I guess
but
um you have to make that a vector three
because it's a float
okay so now I mean this will be huge
yeah
um and they don't collide with
themselves which is good uh so let's
maybe make this
um did my music ends
yeah it did that's okay
um
some bounciness to the blood particles
yeah we could do that uh but before we
do that let's maybe make the scale a
little bit more reasonable
so maybe we could do up to double what
it is
so if we do that times that
then we'll get up to double basically of
what it is so maybe that will be
reasonable
yeah they look different now so you want
to bounce in this I don't know if blood
should bounce though blood doesn't
really bounce
um
but I'm guessing that if we
uh
yeah we've already got that here
actually
um so to make that happen we would
probably
need to
uh how do we set the balanciness in this
new physics engine
maybe we can't
we use our physics materials but that
was about a platform we used physics now
we use drawled
I'll ask Peter
our restitution
it's on the collider I think so if I
make that one
why do I keep getting this
I'm gonna send this to Peter
because that's somewhere here
so basically the entity is not valid
why would that be the case
that's so strange
foreign
but that just looks stupid
my bouncy blood
maybe let's make the friction less
yeah it's pretty it's like every second
time I do that
that's super annoying
that it crashes
I have to track down that bug probably
later
we probably should put this on a
different physics layer so it doesn't
collide with the player
I could quickly try and do that because
otherwise it's weird like I feel like it
shouldn't do that
like blood shouldn't knock other objects
off it should just land on the ground
basically so I'm kind of simulating a
real particle system here and how it
would work with like a GPU based
particle system kind of
um but
if we're going to project settings let's
add another layer called play or and uh
yeah I guess entities which is kind of
like actual game Estes so it does not
collide with particles particles does
not collided with entities
uh and default is kind of the ground I
want to collide with everything so
let's try that
um
so that is an
[Music]
ld53 fix
okay so now they don't
collide
um yeah see every second time I run this
it does this that's so strange
so basically what's happening is we're
trying to set scale I think in the
particle
system but we're trying to do that to to
an entity
that apparently doesn't exist
um
because entities and all
probably I don't know I might do this in
debug mode
I might
track that down and debug later
it's really annoying though because it's
every second time I hit play
and that's very new
I wonder why
and it's coming from that particle
system funnel you know
um I was going to make
the why be a lot
more strong though
well actually in general like this
impossible is not good enough
and uh because the direction is
completely random as well
so let's do plus new Vector three
and let's do zero one zero so like
basically will go up
now we have a little Fountain of blood
and then it's gonna crash all right I'm
sick of this crash let's go debug build
and we'll see
[Music]
I think it's over now
foreign
oh yeah if you had non-uniform scaling
you could scale it down on the up
Direction while extending on the out of
the directions like it was pulling on
the floor that's that's a cool idea
um I might do that
I'm just chasing it and debug mode
that's quite slow
oh what it worked
oh because I had no oh there we go I
mean this isn't a set
so that's I guess incorrect
somehow
oh okay
foreign
[Music]
time
I thought some elements could be voxely
but
I don't know I don't know
I don't know I wasn't really thinking
the whole game just look like
we can
if you guys really want
I don't oh this is
like I guess that's fairly low poly
right but it's not like Boxley like you
know what I mean like the ax wouldn't be
a bunch of little
like a normal
path
and everything will have that outline
effect
I guess I'll send you my hexagon
no
foreign
yeah but I guess
no no it's not
um well yeah it had to be like 1.149 or
something
um because uh
because the radius it was calculating
not like laterally or whatever
[Music]
um it's in the I put it in the chart the
LD games chat
thank you
yeah I didn't like this theme
I voted down this time actually all of
us did
[Music]
but yeah
I'm interested to say like what in
general people
delivery a theme everyone seems to like
really
I don't does anyone watching my stream
actually like
like actually like yeah this theme
foreign
what do you mean
Maybe
yeah players had a cash
I'll change the film out of Shadow packs
end of the first day
what do you mean end of the first day
it's been like two hours
yeah there's countdown timer of course
the countdown timer written on the web
of course it's not it's too hard to do
something like that anyway I wanted to
see like the themes I wanted to see
what the I guess it's not here though
this rat just said personally I'm glad
the theme wasn't your health bar is more
than just a health bar
I don't like this person
foreign
someone said does it matter the goal is
to be the timeline
yeah we're just trying to
make something and submit it
okay
so
Peter is sending me some code
apparently that should do it
a little patch
oh good I can look at what Peter's doing
okay I guess that works
now I can actually get to the problem
Maybe
yeah here it is
so this is coming from
the update function probably
and we're trying to set scale
for an entity that just does not seem to
exist
what does this do well that pram
the edge of the core verify
I guess we can look at this actually
set a scale is called with an invalid
value for parameter entity
yeah so it's trying to set scale on some
so the particle system here
is trying to set
scale on an entity
the
I guess doesn't exist or is invalid
why would I do that though that's not a
good move
because she's really only destroy it
obviously here
and then it removes it at I
wait hold your horses
is that because this is not
oh
oh my goodness I think it's because this
is static
wow that's a big difference though
so does it keep this around even past
stopping
that's the only thing that I can think
of like if we add a uh
on create
that just clears this for example this
list
will that fix it
that's wild
I wonder if
that's intended or whatever
yep that works now
damn okay
I'll tell PETA
make a left oh yeah
well
I don't I don't love them
either all right this is these are the
models chat what do you guys think
um
are you sure you don't like this
well I was imagining it like bigger you
know
right like really comic Reliance that's
okay and also maybe you can have a hat
or whatever like one of those World War
II yeah
yeah the legs the legs are nice
legs are good
I finally I'm adding them
but yeah I don't know I think this would
need too much
I don't know what do you guys what do
you think Chad A or B
job thanks
I love Eggman egg
somebody said it looks like What's
called the microwave
oh yeah I think that I never was a human
ball lovely
oh I'm gonna wait for the stream delay
this is why Peter was annoyed
in chat
wait first let me like write a and b in
a way that persists
and then I can maybe do a poll
engage with your audience
yes no
yes
all right I started a poll for you guys
so you can vote
I mean I'm gonna vote for B but that's
I'm gonna go
well actually like oh no I ruined
everything
[Music]
B is severely weighing 70 today
let's end it
oh whoa what it's just been overtaken
come on guys
[Music]
yeah you guys are very indecisive this
is what I was doing
I don't know
what icon
I can't change my vote
but Tim to be fair that's because you
literally have just a sphere for me
like the fact that it's even close
yeah that's saying something that's
because there's legs are great
[Music]
foreign
well you could have just put the legs I
guess that would be weird there because
everything's boxy
on a
wish
that I could listen
okay so now that I fixed my bug
cause you're right
let's change this to be keyed down
and maybe this to uh I actually never
reset the cooldowns
so that's funny let's make it
[Music]
yeah they definitely have to not have
the Edge outline effects though
[Music]
foreign
Pete is actually kind of working on that
so I don't really want to do too much of
that but where it makes sense just you
know to make it move a little bit I
guess that wouldn't hurt
foreign
[Music]
okay let's do player
whoa okay well that suddenly marked
um
yeah that sucks I
don't know how these new forces work
foreign
cam
um all right
[Music]
foreign
Tim come check out my cool game
ready
oh no
I kind of isn't that kind of cool though
it's pretty cool
no I keep falling off the edge
what if the game is this you have to
deliver the cube from one point of the
map to the other but like it's really
hard like try it
for the full game like because it's
actually really hard on that's blood
let's see you've lost okay now I'm gonna
I'm gonna try and go in the opposite
direction
slowly I don't even know how you
it's hard because the camera is coffee
Can I submit this
holy submission
I love the hexagon
they're gone
pick you up
I mean there is no finish right who says
uh yeah I guess here I am but you
definitely didn't win it you didn't lose
it but you didn't win it
oh yeah yeah
foreign
all right
I feel like we need a nice wartime hdri
so let's go to polyhaven
let me just take all of these assets
I guess someone like I almost want like
a thunderstorm at night or something
uh
yeah they call her
night I use a lot
I know
this
in our lives
and it kind of looks terrible
Sunset would be better
this is kind of cool
now I do kind of like
I I guess I could just do um
I like I think bass Hazel just has
sandbox project I mean just has
this one
yeah I like that one
let's try this
that's your problem
that's fun
crash I need to panic
um
all right
I guess we can see the intensity of one
because it's pretty dark
please
that's really bright because of the
directional line but if we make that
a little bit
like kind of bluish
maybe it was purple 1.3
it's a little colorful
and I mean for one or two we could
probably up the camera exposure although
that's not in me
so let's maybe go back to the Skylight
make it like one
the directional 1.5
it was like old moonlight
and then I was going to also make
although I guess looking at this like
clearly it's not that color
so
maybe it would make it kind of warm
like that
the size of what
you showed me
oh you sent a new one
I
think the legs need to be like half a
size
like the Legacy might need to be tiny
well I mean you could uniformly scale
them as well but yeah
foreign
okay
and I guess I'd also want the light to
come from here I guess it is anyway
though all right
um so there's our light that looks kind
of nice uh oh yeah so I wanted to maybe
tweak these materials a bit
and make them like less rough
I don't know if that's a good idea
but
they'd be like a little bit more glossy
that way
see
and that would mean probably if we
were to turn on screen space Reflections
you can
see the reflection of the player
it's very uh subtle there
uh well there it is it actually looks
pretty dark
oh no
actually you know what's really cool if
some of these were actually rough
so like if blue and green were rough
and then the other ones weren't because
you kind of see like
uh it's really hard to show here
actually I can just use editor camera
but yeah see that
see how the the specular light isn't on
these guys maybe it should be just to a
less degree
but that looks kind of cool
let's just make it like 0.6 or something
so they're still kind of there but like
I mean that's not really there is it can
we tweak this while it's running oh we
can
foreign
that looks kind of dark and then
obviously if we had like a normal map on
them they would look really cool as well
okay what do you think of this Vibe like
graphically
you mean like half the history yeah
well don't worry about the actual sky
box
because we can I mean
you could literally just blur it out
completely and it's a solid color
I just mean more like yeah because see I
made it like dark
and then I kind of made the tiles
reflective as well
kind of cool
the reflectiveness probably not
I'd say I made some of them reflected
some of them not so the specular is like
doesn't go on all of them
I could try
foreign
yeah of course this camera
I mean maybe like one type maybe that
maybe competed in at least two models
though that are completely different
well just so that it's like yeah well I
don't know
leave that to the end
yeah yeah
I wonder how Peter's camera is coming
along
anything that I can pull yet
oh yeah
good I'm just watching his stream now
Hazel crash count is zero for Peter
is that true or has he just not updated
it
yeah
[Music]
Telemetry yeah
that's funny
I feel like streaming on Twitch like
somehow you guys
had way more viewers
like you you apparently have one and
Peter has two and I'm one of I'm one I'm
watching both of your streams
but like I feel like you guys had like
30 or so on Twitch is that was that real
though
why would it be so different you think
people were just browsing twitch for
London dare streams
because a lot of people had had the
whole team up
like I mean it wouldn't be that
difficult to just embed three streams in
an HTML file would it
like I feel like I could do that in two
seconds
in fact I'm going to do that right now
stream
I'm gonna do some voluntary web
programming for some reason
now I'm not a very good web perfect
grandma
sorry don't
didn't I just say I wanted Visual Studio
code
right this is where you ask Chad gbt to
just be like
dock type HTML
HTML what is it like Lang en
that's the proper way because I'm a
proper person and
body
good enough for me
video channel streams
um all right so then let's plop in
the embed
the embed thing
foreign
just try this out
uh
that's cool um
[Music]
okay
oh cool I did it
I think
um so we can do this
and then we can do that
that's me
uh
so that should give us
this right
um so now we just have to do the rest
um
now Tim
yeah can you
go into
I guess on the appetitors as well
actually no don't worry I can just um
and do it publicly
okay
I did it is The Voice version but it's
done Tim
and I could probably make it auto play
and there's no chat obviously I could
also embed chat
but like that's annoying
but that's not bad
um the layout sucks oh maybe I can steal
what's the multi-stream on Twitch
yeah
was it that
something
people blind oh look you're gonna pick
your layout or that fancy
there we go F12 but
a view page source
jupit line that's their way
um
enough for the chat though
the chat's annoying well we I don't know
about having all three chats I mean you
could
but
yeah this is what you're gonna do for
the restroom yeah
for the rest of the day I know why would
I do this yeah the tag is simply
autoplay all right
um
is that like here or is that in the
YouTube thing
that's funny have they actually are they
actually in the process in the process
of development I just did it in two
seconds how long is that process
[Music]
yeah it's okay it's auto play
ER
version two
oh that actually doesn't work
apparently
keep reading between the lines
oh they made some changes
[Music]
do allow autoplay
wow
is someone saying something in chat does
it give me the right answer but I'm just
ignoring it
foreign
oh there's already a thing
sorry I thought this was the I thought
it was link like uh you know that or
whatever didn't realize that was already
a parameter
um okay
that's not what we're playing there
or to play that's funny
hey okay good
so that's autoplay done
[Music]
um
now do I should I try and do some like
style stuff here
where it's like I don't know
hey can be with
100 or whatever
well that's something works
so if we do
50 percent
[Music]
and then maybe Chuck can be on the other
on the other side
but just maybe just like my chat or
something
I don't know how to automatically embed
chat it's always going to be like
now the height can I just make the
height order or something to be 16 9
that doesn't make sense that doesn't
know it's 16 9 does it
I'm not a CSS developer I don't know how
to do this
that sucks
I don't know if I'd have to use
JavaScript to do that or if there's just
like a
how do I make it
wait you can do us but as if that's my
pressure thing
oh what
what I did not know how that was a thing
that must be new
oh my gosh I've done it and then guys
how do I make it on the same line is it
like display block or something weird or
float or
I don't remember
let's play inline
just on that element or like all of them
how does that work
doesn't seem to be working is that
because they don't fit because I made it
too
yeah okay
so we can probably do like 45 45
layout stuff
why is that one so much oh I didn't make
it
against a thousand guys
so that's weird I mean 50 I guess 50 was
like not
good enough like
it's 49 even once all right whatever so
there's the three streams
and then I guess I could do
[Music]
one more
that is like
this is a bit annoying to do but
if I wanted my chat embedded I could
probably
embed the pop-up to the chart
um
[Music]
kind of
makes sense
but I can do it in RBS
do you sure yeah that's the URL I have
an obs so why does that work in IBS I
mean I'm logged in maybe that's why
probably the margin in the body that's
why yeah okay I'm not gonna do that but
yeah
um all right
what if I just go to my channel
there's got to be a public URL right
if I look at this
yeah there you go there's a non-studio
one not YouTube
is basically the same thing
why
why is that not working
is that because they're like actively
blocking it or something
well it works for other people
apparently
not because then there's tutorials that
use it
hmm
and it doesn't need a the width and
aspect ratio is there
ah well maybe it's because of the oh and
there's okay wait no you have to do some
other stuff
apparently okay so this is the your this
is the way this guy did it um
it's
so the V that thing's there so it's not
a pop-up apparently uh and then also
uh
um the embed
domain has to be set are you serious
because I don't have that yet
.com
I'll probably pop it up there but that's
not gonna work locally
is that why because you actually need
the domain to be set here
what if I do like localhost
okay
I don't know
I don't even know how to go get into
Studio Channel
but maybe that would work and in which
case oh let me make the uh do you guys
like what I'm spending my time on by the
way this is good this is how you make a
lot of video games right
uh
hmm
crimson
chocolate that looks Orange
I like orange
nice
I feel like it should be dark mode
okay
foreign
[Music]
Ariel or something like
all right do you guys like that am I a
good web dev can I have a web dev job
now not my hide
will work when you host it okay cool
um
thanks for teaching me CSS guys I
learned two new things today the display
inline and I mean I've used that before
but I just didn't remember it and aspect
ratio which I knew nothing about I did
not know that was a thing that makes it
so easy
okay let me try and hack my server
wait
I've never actually
gone on that specific
for
foreign
now we pivoted
let me just launch this now that I'm
ready to
put on all this hard work I can't just
leave it local
foreign
lead to what the heck is this
feel to that
in America
that's right guys almost almost hacked
in
I just have no idea what the actual
server is for that domain
so I'm looking it up I can't think about
it though okay good ah now I need to
somehow remember the root password
which is easier said than done
but I think now that I don't know
whatsoever it's on I might know the
password
and I don't think
might have to reset the road
it's embarrassing
how is it not any of my like millions of
classifieds that are definitely unique
per website
America
still be out on the town
when we're loving this hell on Earth
as you come down
okay it's definitely the server
okay so now I just need to
like upload a file to it
I don't need to
can I yeah I can
I need a password
can make it here you can make it
anywhere
okay everyone I'm resetting my password
to this but it's okay I will get this
shipped
if there's one thing I shaped during the
slottom data it's going to be this
website
what is this stupid in America song
it's like hit America
come on
quiet
oh there it is
better quickly write that new password
down on a sticky note so I don't forget
it's still not working
are you kidding me
how
or is that a different type of password
this is just a very old so uh that I
don't use for much
I probably probably might be faster to
just change the DNS
to something else
foreign
to get in through that little web
interface
so my son guys
foreign
for some reason
just viruses
this works
I'm not
[__]
mm-hmm
you know what I'm just gonna
I'm gonna say goodbye to that server and
we're going to go on a different server
[Music]
foreign
door is open
like the views
[Music]
foreign
Always by myself
[Music]
because
foreign
[Music]
okay
I think I'm okay now
um
um let's just
what do I do with this
paste it in
I guess I don't have to do that here
foreign
I did it finally
so the URL is Studio china.com
that was very very difficult
[Music]
I sent a link
oh
the 90 of that was trying to remember my
login details so I could deploy this
all right well I think my work is done I
might go and have a break now
that you guys have a website where you
can watch all of our streams I'm gonna
stop one of them
um maybe I'll actually leave what we had
on the screen though it looks kind of
cool
[Music]
it looks very dark doesn't it I think
this is
must I must not have saved ah damn
um no that's interesting one oh the
environment has gone wait what
there we go
that was weird that was better
this is the game so far well from my
side
my job was to make these hexagons and
that's done so
I was playing around with some stuff
as you can see it's fun on as I also did
particles
so they like these blood effects
do normal camera
here they are
they disappear after a while
oh we shouldn't cause Shadows
as well
um all right so
what's next
okay
let's see if we can make a bigger world
ten times bigger
takes a little bit of time
to start up
well as an adult in this physics they're
actually individual physics bodies as
well which isn't the best
foreign
102 thousands or
somewhere or not
we don't have enough space to stop more
Azure bodies you
will Hazel crash though almost
definitely
well it's not hasn't crashed yet
that looks I meant to hit pause but I
hit stop
let's do 128 by 128. obviously there are
better ways of making this you
definitely wouldn't want them to like
all be necessarily entities
um but
this is to stay away
and I kind of want to distress it a bit
but clearly that's too much
how many do we support I think you can
change the amount somewhere
it's real
yeah it is actually
so that exceeds our transform buffer oh
that's right because we can't render
that many
yeah
I probably have to do something a bit
accustomed for that
for that amount
but we we probably would unload
obviously and reload the Trunks and
stuff so it wouldn't quite be like this
now what was I doing let's try 64 by 64
should have probably been like should
probably work
yeah my environment map doesn't seem to
work though ever no no it does
yeah so I guess the problem was really
the fact that their physics bodies which
they don't really need to be like we
could make them not be
I don't really want to go through that
now but
that would make it a lot faster if
they're just entities that are purely
used for rendering but then because
they're all individual though
we can only have like 10 000 transforms
I think well I can just up that number
obviously but the way that the engine is
written right now and these supports
basically like 10 000 entities
so without at least a little bit of
tweaking
which shouldn't be too difficult
to do
but that's if we want but you know this
is a fairly big world I think like as in
you know
you that this is probably enough because
like you can just unload
bits of it
so maybe one chunk can be something like
32 by 32 tiles
and then we can kind of unload you know
different parts of it or whatever
so that's kind of what I'm
thinking yeah that camera is not uh the
real camera Peter's working on the
camera I'm working on the map rendering
and stuff so
that's why uh
wrote I just well wrote I just parented
the camera to the player and called it a
day to so that I could at least have
something
but yeah that's definitely not the way
but it's fun though I kind of like it
don't you think this is a good camera
my blood particles
I don't know I'm spinning
anyway
um
foreign
like have you been in contact with them
do you know how long
okay
because I might head off for a bit now
uh
and yeah
um I just kind of wanted to see what has
changed the way but I guess I can push
what I've done
so let me just
has anyone pushed anything yet
oh oh I might not have right access
either
oh no I should yeah I'm special
[Music]
Prairie Fabs
oh I just modified the main scene
maybe I shouldn't have modified
did Peter make a new scene or is he also
on the main scene
okay good because I didn't
I just use the existing like dummy the
one that the new project made
and I didn't even rename the level
generator's file still called dummy.cs
giving that that's kind of funny
materials yeah the asset registry
definitely needs to
cash stuff well we're probably how to
get ignore
[Music]
I'll commit the stream HTML as well all
right
[Music]
okay I've pushed well I'm
ah
wait what
the remote contains work that you do not
have locally
oh you push something
I didn't hear that
oh you pushed a get ignore file
oh you blocked my massive commit with a
git ignore file why
why does I even need to
now that's gonna cause a little merge
thing or whatever
that's funny I already had it committed
all right
okay done
that is pushed
um
yeah I'm gonna end the stream I guess
and uh
we're going to what id is that social
studio
um
individual Studio code for that little
web side
Quest
um I'm gonna come back in a few hours
maybe in like two or three hours
um and then I'll be streaming for like
another six or so hours probably so
that's the plan
um I'm gonna if I remember risk like
when I restart the stream I'll make it
with lower latency
but yeah
all right see you guys
goodbye